Cuba acaba de perder al famoso trovador
Pablo Milanés una de las Estrellas de la
música en la isla Pablo Milanés nació en
bayamó Cuba en 1943 empezó muy joven su
carrera musical ganando concursos en la
televisión local tras haberse mudado a
la capital la Habana en los años 50 allí
desarrolló su música en 1970 escribió
Yolanda una canción de amor que sigue
siendo un hit en el Continente
latinoamericano
Entonces es mucho más que una una gran
voz versátil una pluma deliciosa y
alguien que que logra vincular la música
con la poesía porque musicalizó de
manera muy afortunada a grandes
escritores de nuestra de nuestra lengua
el que apoyó a la revolución cubana
incorporó su lucha social en sus
canciones
estuvo en el origen del movimiento nueva
Trova que fundió con Silvio Rodríguez y
Noel Nicolás un estilo musical que
cuenta historias enfocadas en el
socialismo el colonialismo y el racismo
a lo largo de su carrera Milanés produjo
más de 40 discos ganó varios premios
Grammy latinos incluso uno en 2015 por
excelencia musical en honor a una vida
dedicada a la música en los últimos años
se puso más crítico contra la revolución
cubana pidiendo reformas sociales y
económicas y más libertades se mudó a
Madrid en 2017 donde recibía
tratamientos por un cáncer de la sangre
yo su último concierto en Cuba en junio
de este año un despido final antes de
fallecer con 79 años